he's the founder of pro football talk
he's on pro football talk live co-host
with Chris Simms his latest article Drew
Rosenhaus Colin Kaepernick should get
signed his Colin Kaepernick represented
by Drew Rosenhaus is his football rights
Mike no no Jeff Nally represents Colin
Kaepernick it has for several years now
but rosenhouse a prominent agent spoke
to NBC News and shared that opinion and
I feel like this time around more people
are speaking openly about what the NFL
needs to do as it relates to Colin
Kaepernick and I think we're just
waiting you see if one of the 32 teams
will do something bring him in for a
work out negotiate with him on a
contract and maybe add him to the roster
now that the mood seems to be a lot
different than it was when the
blackballing began three and a half
years ago do we know if Kaepernick wants
to play if he is going to be a backup
quarterback definitely wants to play
definitely willing to be a backup I
think it's going to be a challenge to
work out the great contract because from
one perspective you could say then he
should just take whatever he can get
even if it's the minimum salary from the
other perspective and I think this is
part of a notion that the pendulum is
swinging the other way you put
Kaepernick's name and number on an NFL
jersey of one of the 32 teams that
jersey probably becomes the highest
selling jersey immediately coast to
coast that team develops a national
following immediately you know teams do
the hard knock show because they want to
have a national following and it never
happens this is a way if you're looking
for a national platform this is the way
to do it so there is value in having him
onto the team from a business standpoint
whereas four years ago people were
afraid to have him on the team from a
business standpoint and also he's going
to help your team get better we've
looked at a lot of the depth charts and
I start with Houston Texas who fits
better as the backup to deshaun Watson
given his skillset AJ McCarron our Colin
Kaepernick it's that simple
it's a no-brainer it's Kaepernick not
McCarran I thought Kansas City would be
a soft landing spot with Andy Reid you
know you got the most secure player in
football and Patrick mahomes and I
thought you know they just won the Super
Bowl
you could bring in Colin Kapernick and
mahomes would welcome that because some
of these quarterbacks I wonder if
Russell Wilson welcomed Colin Kaepernick
I just don't know what to make of that
Pete Carroll story Mike because why
would a coach call Pete Carroll or
somebody in the front office Pete
Carroll didn't spend much time with
Colin Kaepernick I'd be calling Jim
Harbaugh or Greg Roman before I'd be
calling Pete Carroll explain that to me
well I've said this a few years ago
Colin Kaepernick will help you win
championships with an S not one but
multiple but he is a guy that people
should be talking to and the whole
Seahawks thing is weird to me they
didn't sign it because they regard him
as a starter well why did you bring him
in for a visit then if you were looking
for a backup when you regard him as a
starter he never had a workout with the
Seahawks they view him as a starter I'm
back in 2017 to head to deeper issues on
that team they had guys in that locker
room that resented Russell Wilson that
maybe would have lined up behind Colin
Kaepernick if he was on the team and
created a problem as to whether or not
maybe Russell Wilson should be benched
for Colin Kaepernick I think that's one
of the reasons they steered clear I even
bring him in if that's the case that's
what's odd about it but but according to
Kara
somebody's doing their due diligence
somebody's interested and I really do
think that the atmosphere is much
different now than it was three years
ago and I'd like to think somebody's
gonna take a step back and say hey there
may be a segment of the fan base that
isn't happy about this well to hell with
them if they if they want a huff and
puff
go ahead we've got a lot more people now
who will embrace us for giving Colin
Kaepernick the chance he's been denied
for the last three years I've seen
people speculate on where Colin
Kaepernick could end up and I don't know
if you caught my interview with Doug
Williams who works with the Redskins and
I did say hey have you guys thought
about Colin Kaepernick and he goes no
because of President Trump the military
that's in Washington DC and you know now
I get to your initiative where now we're
looking at that nickname for you know
Washington's team I don't know if Daniel
Snyder would enter
tane that i don't know if it would hey
all I can bring in Kapernick just let me
keep my nickname like I don't know how
any of this works but I don't put it
past any of these owners what do you
make of Washington DC first of all with
what Doug Williams said well if you
start calling Kapernick there's a chance
the first thing he says it is
interesting I've been waiting for
somebody in that organization to stand
up in this moment if we are taking a
stand against racism in all forms if
they are taking down the Christopher
Columbus statue in Richmond Virginia
where the team has its training camp the
conversation is expanded beyond racism
against black Americans Native Americans
who were shoved out of the way when the
Europeans came over 500 plus years ago
those Native Americans have a seat at
this table - and it's astounding to me
and we've been pushing this for a week
and a half now and I've been hoping and
praying that somebody will catch on to
it and run with it and somebody from
within the team I mean this is the time
where it is courageous anymore to stand
up and say the right thing and do the
right thing and I just keep waiting for
whether it's the coach whether it's one
of the players whether it's somebody to
say hey you know what we're taking a
stand against racism this name is a
dictionary defined slur now is the time
to change and I keep waiting and hoping
that to make this moment complete and to
give the NFL a true way to impact you
know it's it's one thing to issue
statements and videos and throw money at
the problem and it's that's fine that's
needed but if you really want to prove
that things are different
NASCAR gets rid of Confederate flag the
NFL changes the Washington nickname and
repairs Colin Kaepernick gets him to
where he would be right now if you
hadn't wrongfully been denied a job the
last three and a half years talking to
Mike Florio from Pro Football Talk Baker
Mayfield JJ Watt Bill O'Brien talking
about taking a knee here you know that's
why I go back to you know you can you
kind of snuck that in with the Texans
might be a great spot here and knowing
your relationship with Bill O'Brien
I wonder if Bill O'Brien a coach is
going to take a knee you got a secure
quarterback and deshaun Watson and you
could bring in Colin Kaepernick man
might might be able to put a nice little
bow on this hey Dan it's a no-brainer
and I thought of it last week when I
combined the heartfelt message that Bill
O'Brien had almost two weeks ago when he
first addressed the George Floyd murder
and his feelings on where things
currently stand in the country Bill
O'Brien who's both the coach and the GM
of the Houston Texas so he doesn't have
to say well the GM didn't let me sign
this guy he has that authority he
attended the George Floyd funeral last
week in Houston Tom McNair the owner of
the team was there and that was the
moment when I was shocked and said this
isn't about putting Colin Kaepernick
back towards about repairing him it's
for me you know the best argument now
for not signing Colin Kaepernick is well
he hasn't played in three years and you
mentioned the Chiefs
I mean if Andy Reid is the guy who gave
Mike Vick a second chance after two
years out of football for something he
did why not give Colin Kaepernick it's I
hate to even use the word second chance
a second chance implies there's a need
for a second chance why not be the one
to bring him back after three years and
give him an opportunity to get to where
he otherwise would have been after being
wrongfully denied employment the last
three years and speaking to you know
African American who's still in the NFL
and he said last year until the white
stars get behind this it will not have
if it won't have the movement the
momentum that we need and now you're
talking about Baker Mayfield and JJ Watt
and you know a coach in the NFL who's
willing to do this I get the feeling
that you might be in the minority if
you're not kneeling on game day what do
you think is going to happen and I know
we got a lot of time before we get to
September but what do you think the
sidelines are gonna look like well you
know it's funny Justin Jackson the
Chargers last week we've made the
comment that there's a chance by the
time we get to September there'll be no
need to kneel because the change will be
happening to the point where there isn't
the importance to bring attention to the
problem but I think as of right now
based upon where we are based upon where
we likely will be in September there
will be a lot of people kneeling and a
lot of Baker Mayfield message because
it's the message the NFL should have had
from day one I'm doing the right thing
here and if I lose fans
over it I don't care the nfl's problem
in 2017 is they feared that there would
be a segment of the fanbase that would
turn away from them it would affect them
in the pocketbook it affect them in the
TV ratings and to a certain extent the
anthem controversy did affect the NFL
that year the world is different though
this time around and I think the NFL
needs to go back and throw away the
playbook from 2017 and recognize that
you know what first of all anybody who
does refuse to watch football and a lot
of people will say they refuse to watch
and still watch but if they are gonna
turn away from us that's their problem
we don't want their business if that's
how they think if they refuse to
understand that kneeling during the
anthem isn't disrespect of the flag the
military in the country and secondly
maybe there is a net gain here as I said
earlier we sell jerseys we sell tickets
we develop a national following because
we're the ones who stood up and did the
right thing NBA season opener still on
time but where do we stand with fans in
the stands well I'm concerned about the
things that I'm hearing and I know that
the media has moved on to a large extent
from the coronavirus but when you see
the spikes in some of these states and
when you see states reopening and
nightclubs packed with people and no
masks in sight I'm just concerned that
when we get to September it's gonna be
impossible to have fans at these games I
just hope that they can come up with
procedures and protocols that the Union
the league the coaches everybody are on
the same page about you know there's a
protocol out there the Union hasn't
agreed to it John Harbaugh was
complaining about it last week take a
lot of work to do to come up with a
system that gets everyone on the same
page and it keeps the virus off of the
playing field out of the locker room and
off of the plane can that locker means
usually a petri dish and the playing
field is worse and they better have a
good plan are they gonna get this thing
started and it's gonna fall apart by the
end of September NFL owners on the clock
here for that franchise tag and can you
sing I know that it's been dak Prescott
and I know there are other players there
and gaku a and AJ green here but it is
they're like the worst case scenario for
the Cowboys with dak Prescott is what
well worst-case scenario is they don't
get a deal done with him before July 15
so they can't do a multi-year deal for
2020 then he holds out of training camp
in the preseason then shows up a week
before the opener like Le'Veon Bell did
three years ago and the Cowboys have to
decide that we go in Andy Dalton who's
ready to go or do we go with a guy who's
just walked through the door and they
don't do that long-term deal by July 15
you've got that Prescott on the Kurt
cousins plan where it's thirty-one point
four million this year
thirty-seven point eight million next
year 2022
it's either 45 million if they use the
transition tag 54 million if they use
the franchise tag a third time or he
walks away into free agency and see
that's what this comes down to Dan it's
a very simple analysis what will the
Cowboys offer that Prescott to give up
69 million dollars over the next two
years plus a shot at free agency like
Kirk Cousins got what will it take to
get him to trade that trade that in
that's the challenge and that's what the
Cowboys have to answer and they have to
come up with enough to get him to trade
in what he currently hasn't seen good to
talk to you Mike hope you're well we
appreciate your time as always all right
Dan see buddy that's Mike Florio pro
football talk live Pro Football Talk